[Musique]
catherine mennecier bonjour merci sur le
plateau tv fil 78 pour un nouveau vip
qui vous est consacré vous êtes
yvelinoise et vous êtes aussi chef de
choeur gospel et à marier le roi ouais
bon comme on en arrive à assat avec chef
de choeur gospel commencent à arriver
dans votre vie dans ma vie à moi c'est
oui à une voie là ça a un parcours un
petit peu atypique puisque moi à la base
je suis dessinatrice dans la pub
dans celui-ci n'a rien à voir et pendant
25 ans j'ai fait ce métier là mais comme
j'ai j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
chan la danse et bien j'avais j'avais un
jeu participé en tant que chanteuse
choriste dans un dans une petite chorale
elle est d'accord voilà gospel à la base
mais avant j'avais fait du rock de la
soul l'arc du français du tout tout tout
tout ce que voilà gmail amusé que
j'aimais la musique est un moment donné
voilà j'ai fait le choix de consacrer
donc ma vie au chant gospel pour
différentes raisons mais surtout parce
que ben je vois là ç'a pris énormément
de place ça commençait à prendre plus de
place que je ne pensais eh bien le
travail dans la publicité a commencé à
décliner je n'ai pas relancer la machine
comme j'avais pu le faire parce que 25
25 ans en freelance c'est quand même
long et et voilà il ya des hauts et des
bas quand on est indépendant et là j'ai
décidé que bon voilà je quittais ce
métier pour en reprendre un autre
alors concrètement qu'est-ce que comment
on fait parce que c'est bien gentil se
dire je veux être chanteuse mais mais
alors c'est pas je veux être chanteuse
sait qu'à un moment donné c'est s'est
imposée parce que voilà j'ai une j'ai
une particularité c'est que je suis
curieuse donc quand je commence une
activité jamais lien j'aime bien rentré
plus profondément dans l'apprentissage
de cette quelle qu'elle soit il se
trouve qu'à un moment donné j'ai essayé
puisque je ça achoppé sur certains
points le gospel le chant gospel et la
musique puisque quand même j'ai appris
le piano j'avais 45 ans donc c'était
voilà c'était il fallait que je
réapprenne un changement de vie de se
taire oui et puis ils sont meilleurs et
et voilà je suis parti en formation donc
dans une école qui s'appelle aujourd'hui
cdc france et qui m'a tout appris qui
m'a appris
comment comment respirer comment chanter
comment me tenir
comment quelle attitude avoir scénarisé
ça comme ont chorégraphié et ensuite m'a
appris aussi ce que ça vous laisse que
ça ni signifiait le gospel crée alors
qu'est ce que ça signifie un chant sacré
chant sacré chant sacré alors j'en ai un
peu feignant écriture j'ai alors culture
générale très très très très rapidement
c'est un style musical qui prend sa
source dans l'esclavagé entre le 18e et
le 19e siècle aux états unis alors que
les esclaves qui avaient été arrachées
de leurs terres ont absorbé d'une
certaine manière la culture musicale de
l'époque dans les églises protestantes
où il avait la permission après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé d'accéder à
la et ils ont fait un mélange en fait
entre entre leur leur propre style
musical et 7 ce style musical là donc
c'est un métissage c'est un mélange moi
d'accord et donc le gospel c'est avant
tout la rythmique parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est la rythmique dans
le gospel est extrêmement importante
parce que si on se rappelle de
l'histoire de ces esclaves pour
supporter de tenir de huy de tenir je
veux dire la cadence en fait dans les
champs de canne à sucre notamment qu' un
travail on se rend pas compte mais
absolument terrible au niveau physique
parce que d'abord la came sucre sa coupe
sa coupe limon des doigts et surtout il
faut se baisser et il faut avoir un
mouvement très régulier pour pouvoir
avancer
d'accord donc être à l'aise avec ça mais
bien évidemment bien évidemment c'est
évident je vous propose une chose oui on
va écouter un extrait oui et on en
reparle après d'accord
à
nous
et
ouais
oui
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
voilà donc on parlait du rythme
effectivement ces visuels aussi c'est
très visuellement du corps qui
exactement qui va avec
avec le chant voilà c'est à dire qu'en
gospel en tout cas à seeds of joy là où
je m excuse c'est le nom du coeur que
j'ai fondé en 2009
oui j'ai vraiment eu à coeur c'est le
cas de le dire de de transmettre une
notion importante qui n'est pas
forcément très connu en france c'est à
dire qu'on ne chante pas qu'avec sa
bouche
d'accord on chante avec son corps tout
entier on chante avec ses mains chante
avec ses bras ou chante avec ses pieds à
chanter moi là et le gospel nous rejoint
vraiment en cela en france où on manque
beaucoup d'expressions corporelles ça
veut pas dire qu'on ne danse pas et ses
amis mais le chant c'est souvent un
champ on l'a soit la variété qui est
bien déjà et soit le chant au savon
c'est à dire classique entre tout ça
c'est un crayonné
c'est à dire qu' il manque une immense
qu'une comment dire il manque une mode
d'expression qui est rejointe par le
gospel
on a quoi +57 sa complète à mon sens
absolument
en plus de ça c'est un chant en anglais
oui et c'est un chant sacré mais qu'on
ne comprend son deux chanteuses grecques
ont le chanteur ray certainement pas en
france est d'accord alors on va vous
avez fait cette formation pendant
combien de temps cinq ans 50 de
formation en plus de mon travail ouais
d'accord donc après vous décidez nom de
votre coeur alors enfin en même temps en
pendant que j'étais en train de faire
cette formation il m'est venue cette
idée impérieuse de monter un choeur
gospel
voilà que vous dirigez et donc j'écris
aujourd'hui en a soixante soixante
personnes
mais on a commencé on était 12 oui
d'accord voilà ça fait un moment où ça
va bien le roi ça marly le roi est alors
quelle est la motivation de ces gens
c'est ce qu'on peut dire parfois c'est
une thérapie c
alors dit à plusieurs choses bien aimé
bah oui oui bien sûr c'est
multifactoriel
d'abord le chant c'est comme ça devrait
être prescrit par la sécurité sociale
c'est vrai mais bien sûr ça fait
derrière ça fait énormément de bien
parce qu'on fait appel au souffle
enfermé dans une posture ont fait appel
aussi à la mémoire il faut être
concentré je dirige donc il faut être
il faut être concentré se voir pour
savoir curiosité qui sont vos chanteurs
que ce choeur il est constitué de quel
genre de personne alors il n'y a pas mal
les âges
oui suis pas de 1000 da enfin c'est à
partir de 18 ans quoi qu'il en soit ça
s'est su avant non pas avant parce qu'il
ya une responsabilité que je ne veux pas
prendre
voilà donc ces jeux je veux des gens
qu'ils soient qu'ils sachent exactement
à quoi s'en tenir et majeur et jusqu'à
on a on a une des choristes qui sont
allés jusqu'à 75 d'accord voilà
mais pour anthracite of joy il faut être
au courant de ce qui va s'y passer c'est
à dire que je reçois tout le monde je
vais faire des auditions et je discute
avec la personne parce que les personnes
qui cherchent par exemple à se détendre
ou à prendre du plaisir du bon temps ce
n'est pas d'emblée ce qu'ils vont
trouver dans le coeur parce que c'est un
loisir exigeant mais quand le chant
gospel est un loisir exigeant et
concrètement à dire quoi concrètement
c'est à dire que déjà c'est un chant qui
ne qui n'a pas de partition donc c'est
un chant qui s'apprend à l'oreille oui
d'accord qui ont fait mal à la mémoire à
la mémoire ghana les lettres des
marolles exactement à mettre sa partie
il faut s'entraîner au niveau du rythme
aussi lorsqu'il ya un investissement
physique et donc là où on prend du
plaisir est là où vraiment il ya une
détente c'est que tous ensemble tendus
vers le même but et le but du gospel
acids and joy c'est de transmettre le
message du gospel le message de ghost
deschamps bien évidemment a donc
le champ un chant sacré qui prend sa
source dans le nouveau testament pour le
gospel parce que god spell parole de
dieu
donc c'est l'évangile donc on parle
beaucoup de jésus et donc mai
même si on n'est pas croyant le but à 6
of joy c'est de rendre au plus juste
l'intention du champ donc quand on parle
de 2,2 du chagrin on doit exprimer le
chagrin on doit aller chercher
profondément soit sans pour autant le
vivre mais exprimé le chagrin quand on
est dans l'espoir un acteur et voilà on
est des acteurs dont nous sommes des
acteurs du champ et souvent les on est
là pour le public on l a déjà pour nous
nourrir nous ensemble pour faire corps
et puis ensuite ensuite transmettre
transmettre le message
absolument d'accord et vous donner des
cours aussi je crois oui les cours ont
bien gras particulier en petit groupe et
tout le monde peut chanter
enfin une fois qu'on a correspond à vos
cris je ne peux chanter on ne partent
pas tous du même du même jeu mais moins
haut mais si on fait un travail honnête
et sincère on peut arriver à quelque
chose
d'accord j'ai dix mois à leurs côtés ce
qu'on peut vous voir en concert ce
malheur des conserves des tournées voilà
ça c'est pas encore détourne encore on
anime des cultes on anime des messes ont
fait des concerts le monde alors sur de
m'engager ma vie des mariages aussi oui
bien évidemment
et on se produira le prochain concert
c'est le 29 avril à 20h30 je crois me
suis lassé à marly-le-roi la salle des
fêtes de marly dans la salle des fêtes
donc pas de direct et féminisé pour
l'instant non c'est vrai que le lieu le
plus le lieu où le gospel s'exprime le
mieux et dans une église mais là la
ville de marly nous prêtent
généreusement cette salle qui compte 400
places et en général c'est une fête
extraordinaire quoi c'est vraiment un
rendez vous et à comment ça se passe
avec les publics justement alors nous il
ya une communion une pause on va en fait
on fait partageux fait partager beaucoup
vous promener dans la sage le problème
est oui les solistes se promène dans la
salle avec les incite à se promener là
il ya plusieurs solistes ah oui bien sûr
il ya quatre quatre solistes d'accord
qui se partagent les solos et vous vous
dirigez ça comme un chef d'orchestre
dirige alain
un orchestre oui si on veut en mon
intention aussi c'est de laisser le cas
le plus autonome possible c'est à dire
qu'il ya certains champs où je les
laisse se débrouiller et je fais chanter
aussi beaucoup le public je fais
beaucoup relier un reer homélie mais le
fait que sur des champs simple parce que
nous sommes très pudique en france 1
nous sommes des publics
on a du mal à se laisser aller à séville
en 2005 comme ça vous avez un peuple
comme ça il faut respecter cette date à
l'esprit la faut respecter le fait que
non se lève pas tout de suite d'emblée
non ne frappe pas dans ses mains tout de
suite il faut amener le public en a on
n'a pas envie à en avoir en est ce que
je vois ce portal et seulement et au
bout d'un match
voilà exactement à oui oui bien sûr oui
mais c'est pour c'est ça qui nous anime
en fait c'est ça qui vous anime à
l'écouté merci catherineau va vous
retrouvez donc marie leroy side of joy
battre le favori et 29 avril
on sera là et merci de nous avoir fait
découvrir votre passion on peut dire oui
merci merci
[Musique]